les effets de la coved 19 chez les
enfants ont été une des plus grandes
questions de la pandémie
on sait que les plus jeunes réagissent
pas au virus de la même manière que les
adultes seraient pas dire qu'ils sont
complètement immunisé
certains enfants ont même développé des
complications très graves mais la vaste
majorité des cas de kobe 19 chez les
plus jeunes sont considérés comme légers
ou asymptomatiques les choses par contre
sont moins claires pour ce qui est du
rôle des enfants dans la propagation de
la maladie
ici jusqu'à maintenant les écoles on
pourrait considérer comme un point
transmission important on ne sait pas si
l'arrivée des variants doit il changer
quelque chose
est ce qu'on sait pourquoi les enfants
sont moins affectés pour l'instant on
n'a que des hypothèses
la première implique une différence
importante entre le système immunitaire
des enfants et celui des adultes
chez l'adulte il arrive que le système
immunitaire et agissent de façon très
agressive face à la corée de 10,9 au
point où il va déclencher ce qu'on
appelle une tempête de cytokines une
réaction incontrôlée qui peut aller
jusqu à endommager les poumons
al'inverse le système immunitaire des
enfants est beaucoup plus tolérants face
à l'inconnu et peut réagir de façon plus
modérée face à la kfw de 19 ce qui leur
évite de développer les conséquences les
plus graves de la maladie
une autre hypothèse impliquant récepteur
qu'on appelle à ses e 2 pour le virus
cette protéine c'est une vraie porte
d'entrée qui lui permet d'en virer de
prendre contrôle de nos cellules
mais les cellules qui possèdent ce
récepteur à co2 varient beaucoup selon
notre âge chez l'adulte
on les retrouve un peu partout y compris
dans notre système respiratoire du nez
jusqu'aux poumons chez les enfants on en
retrouve dans le nez dans la gorge mais
il y en a beaucoup moins dans les
poumons
ce qui fait que le virus ont beaucoup
plus de difficultés à s'installer et que
les enfants ne vont pas développer des
maladies aussi graves que celles des
adultes les enfants sont ils moins
contagieux
c'est le coeur du problème on sait que
en ce qui concerne certains virus les
enfants sont un vecteur très important
de transmission
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi en cas
d'épidémie de grippe par exemple la
fermeture des écoles peut être une très
bonne stratégie pour réduire la
propagation
pour ce qui est de la kfw de 19 les
choses sont un peu moins clair les
données qu'on a accumulées depuis le
début de la pandémie suggère que les
enfants de moins de 10 ans transmettent
- le virus que les adultes
certaines études vont même jusqu'à
suggérer que ces enfants sont jusqu'à
cinq ans pour cent moins contagieux que
ne le sont les adultes plus âgés et
qu'on comprenne pas exactement par quel
mécanisme ce phénomène est possible
ce risque augmente toutefois avec l'âge
et on voit une hausse progressive de la
propagation chez les enfants de 12 à 17
ans jusqu'à ce qu'il rejoigne les
niveaux qu'on voit chez les adultes
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi les
mesures de distanciation qu'on voit aux
primaires ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles qu'on voit pour les cycles
supérieurs
les écoles sont elles un lieu de
propagation beaucoup d'études à travers
le monde suggère que jusqu'à maintenant
les écoles ne sont pas un moteur de la
pandémie
la plupart des éclosions qu'on y trouve
sont minimes avec un ou deux cas par
classe et les enfants qui sont impliqués
n'ont pas propagé la maladie entre eux
mais ils ont plutôt attrapé d'un adulte
que ce soit un enseignant ou un parent à
la maison mais les risques de
transmission la kfw 19 à l'école ne sont
pas nulles
tout est une question de probabilité et
puisque les écoles sont un des rares
lieux publics ouverts en ce moment c'est
donc normal qu'on y trouve des cas de
transmission de la maladie
la fermeture des écoles peut aussi
entraîner des conséquences très
importantes sur le bien-être des enfants
il faut donc à tout prix comprendre ce
qui se passe sur le terrain avant de
décider quelles mesures mettre en place
pour réduire la transmission de la
maladie dans les écoles est ce que les
nouveaux variants agissent différemment
chez les enfants présentement on n'a pas
assez d'études pour répondre clairement
à cette question
par contre des données en provenance de
la grande-bretagne et qui font face aux
variants d117 depuis l'automne dernier
nous montre que ce variant et plus
transmissible pour toutes les tranches
d'âge et sa 5 lui les enfants par contre
comme on a vu au cours de la dernière
année les enfants restent moins sensible
à ce variant que ne le sont les adultes
on a donc vu une hausse de la
transmission de crever 19 chez les plus
jeunes depuis l'arrivée des variants en
grande bretagne mais cette hausse reste
proportionnelle à la plus grande
contagiosité du virus
ce variant ne cible pas les jeunes de
façon différente et la quantité
d'hospitalisation qu'on a vu pour cette
tranche d'âge ne pas augmenter de façon
importante depuis l'arrivée des variants
par contre pour les chercheurs
l'arrivée des variances suggère qu'on
doit revoir toutes nos mesures de
précaution dans toutes les tranches de
la société et ça inclut pour les plus
jeunes et pour les écoles
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
à nous les faire parvenir à l'adresse
que vous voyez à l'écran et nous on va y
répondre le plus rapidement possible